[Music]
Shaquille O'Neal in the movie and it
surprised me because I've met have a
bunch of times and he's such a funny guy
and he's got one of your than any of us
yeah swear to god there's all comedians
in the movie every time you do a scene
everybody walk away you know jack is
funnier than me he's like the nicest
greatest guy and we hung out
with the Shaq and we get and we all play
basketball a lot of us so we play
basketball we got to get back to the
movie set Shaq has to take a shower so
everyone's like alright we'll see you
later shag in my head I'm like I gotta
see Shaq's penis I mean for historical
reasons like the Grand Canyon you got
this completely thank you so my plan was
to kinda I hear the shower go on in the
back when he's showering away just not
you know being the Shaq down there in
the showers everyone else left I'm like
alright let me see that thing
I'm walking backwards doing my routine
getting closer to the shower and then I
turn around and I go alright I gotta see
Jack's thing right now his bodyguard sir
his bodyguard is just so strong and big
and like this thick neck bald head this
one eyes looking at me just one eye so I
said sorry I was just trying to see you
Shaq's penis I'm out of here
please don't tell jack okay this
happened so I see Jack later on the set
and I was like I guarantee that guy
ratted me out so I said Jack sorry about
that before with you with your security
guard and he goes I don't got a security
guard that was my dick
[Music]
[Applause]
you